[Musica]
buon pomeriggio a tutti e io sono una
biologa marina se sono una biologa
marina lo devo al mio jump che nel 1980
mi ha portato dalla natia toscana e
dagli studi che facevano l'università di
siena alla stazione geologica a napoli
ero una giovane studentessa e facevo la
mia prima comunicazione a un congresso
di biologia marina ad ancona e tutto mi
sarei aspettata alla fine del mio
intervento
tranne di ricevere una una critica
ferocissima ai risultati che avevo
presentato e all'approccio da parte di
un gigante all'epoca della biologia
marina italiana e professore gennaio
fioresi che mi piace ricordare è chiaro
che superato lo choc del momento venni
estremamente stimolata a capire che cosa
avevo sbagliato e quindi concordai anche
come e mentori di siena di venire a
napoli
affrontare il toro per le corna come si
dice e concordare di venire a lavorare
con frasi che all'epoca lavorava al
laboratorio di ischia che è la sede
distaccata della stazione zoologica di
napoli è lì è cambiato tutto il corso
della mia vita perché io lavoro e vivo
ormai tra ischia e napoli alla stazione
zoologica dal 1983 e da una quindicina
di anni mi occupo delle problematiche
legate agli effetti del cambiamento
climatico sugli organismi marini del
vento cioè tutto quell'insieme di
organismi che vivono nei fondali marini
o a stretto contatto con fondali marini
e degli ecosistemi costieri del
mediterraneo
il cambiamento climatico è un
attualmente un noto topic della ricerca
direi mondiale di biologia ed ecologia
marina e interessa ormai la comunità
scientifica in maniera molto molto ampia
e come avete avuto modo di vedere ormai
non c'è giorno che nei media non venga
nominata qualche problematica collegata
con il climate change
quindi il in particolare negli ultimi 60
anni si è assistito a una profondissima
trasformazione del rapporto tra l'uomo e
l'ambiente naturale ed uno degli aspetti
e dei parametri fondamentali di questo
impatto fortissimo antropogenico sul
sull'ambiente naturale è proprio la
l'aumento della co2 in atmosfera che è
aumentata del 40 per cento
dall'epoca preindustriale ad oggi quindi
negli ultimi circa 200 anni e l'anno
scorso ha superato quel valore soglia di
400 ppm quindi parti per milione che è
considerato un valore molto critico dai
giochi mici e dai biologi proprio per la
biologia di tantissime specie che
inclusa inclusa la nostra però il in
questo scenario che quindi che prevede
anche livelli di riscaldamento molto
elevati per un futuro non lontano
stiamo parlando di prossimi 50 anni
della fine di questo secolo quindi gli
oceani svolgono un ruolo nella
regolazione del clima mondiale un ruolo
direi fondamentale perché innanzitutto
con gli organismi proprio viventi gli
oceani assorbono attualmente un quarto
delle emissioni di co2 di natura
antropogenica quindi quelle emesse dalla
combustione dei fossili dei e della
deforestazione
questo però assorbimento della co2 a una
un'altra faccia della medaglia è l'altra
faccia del problema è che la co2
interagendo con l'acqua di mare forma un
surplus di acido carbonico che è un
acido debole ma è pur sempre un acido e
liberali ioni idrogeno
voi sapete tutti che l'acidità si misura
con il ph il ph misura appunto la
concentrazione degli ioni idrogeno
quindi una misura indiretta dell'acidità
e lo misura come logaritmo è negativo di
questa concentrazione quindi c'è un
surplus di acido carbonico che acidifica
l'acqua in pratica è come se noi
versassi ma quasi dell'anti calcare
nell'acqua e quindi ha un potere anche
corrosivo vedremo e sempre soprattutto
sui carbonati e poi abbiamo un surplus
di ioni idrogeno i quali a loro volta
sequestrano sono molto reattivi
sequestrano gli ioni di carbonato e li
sottraggono cosa al calcio e quindi sia
una riduzione di cosa del carbonato di
calcio il carbonato di calcio è
importantissimo perché il carbonato di
calcio e il mattone fondamentale con la
quale moltissimi organismi costruiscono
i propri gusci e proprio scheletri anche
il nostro scheletro ha impregnato di
carbonato di calcio e quindi dai
microorganismi fino ai pesci in ambiente
marino c'è questa sottrazione di
carbonato di calcio quindi abbiamo un
ambiente più corrosivo in cui c'è una
depauperamento del carbonato di calcio
in questo scenario è chiaro che gli
organismi che saranno più penalizzati da
questo tipo di problemi saranno appunto
gli organismi calcare si parla di
acidificazione marina quindi tutto
questo complesso di reazioni va sotto il
nome di alterazione della del ph e della
chimica pop si chiama chimica dei
carbonati va sotto il nome di
acidificazione marina o ocean
acidification la troverete nella
letteratura internazionale
si parla di ozzy ha sedi fiction da 20
25 anni
e i geo chimici si sono accorti che
dall'inizio dell'epoca industriale ad
oggi c'è stato già una riduzione di 0 1
0 2 unità del ph e che se sì se
l'emissione di co2 continuano allo
stesso tasso di oggi ci sarà addirittura
una riduzione di 03 04 ulteriori unità
non vi lasciate ingannare dai decimali
perché essendo il ph espresso come
logaritmo le variazioni anche di decimi
di grado implicano variazioni di acidità
molto forti e variazioni molto forti
della concentrazione degli ioni idrogeno
quindi sono scenari per la fine di
questo secolo molto preoccupanti ripeto
soprattutto per gli organismi calcarei
pensate a un solo habitat le barriere
coralline che sostengono tra l'altro la
la vita e l'economia di quasi due
miliardi di persone sul nostro pianeta
ma in questo scenario che vi ho diciamo
sintetizzato vi chiederete chi quale
aspetto c'entra il golfo di napoli
centra il nostro golfo il nostro
territorio la nostra casa il golfo di
napoli è probabilmente una delle aree
costiere più complesse che noi abbiamo
nel mediterraneo e la piu complessa dal
punto di vista geomorfologico e
vulcanologico come noi ben sappiamo ma è
anche una delle aree fortunatamente tra
le più conosciute al mondo per la
presenza ormai da oltre 150 anni di
numerose istituzioni scientifiche
universitarie cnr la stazione geologica
in cui lavoro io in particolare la parte
nord del golfo di napoli quella definita
dai campi flegrei e dalle isole flegree
gli schiavi vara e procida ischia tra
l'altro è la più grande delle isole
flegree
sono ben conosciute fino a
dall'antichità per la loro attività
vulcanica e ischia direi che ce l'ha
ricordato in maniera molto drammatica
allo scorso anno con il terremoto di
agosto e numerosissimi sono i fenomeni
di vulcanesimo secondario ischia
famosissima per le terme per le acque
termali per i fanghi ed anche per le
fumarole sia emerse e sia sommerse e
sono proprio le fumarole sommerse cioè
queste zone in cui come in una jacuzzi
il gas da zone di frattura della crosta
della crosta terrestre
esce questo gas sono questi ecosistemi
questi sistemi molto molto interessanti
perché questo gas intorno a ischia è per
il 90 95 per cento anidride carbonica
non ci sono gas cosiddetti tossici per
esempio sul fuori o il metano e questo
gas esce alla stessa temperatura delle
acque circostanti
quindi noi assistiamo ad un un surplus
di co2 che acidifica in maniera direi
naturale questi sistemi senza la
variazione lacko variazione di altri
fattori per esempio la salinità la
temperatura e senza la presenza di gas
tossici
e possibile quindi studiare in questi
sistemi che noi consideriamo dei veri e
propri laboratori a cielo aperto
laboratorio naturali è possibile
studiare
adesso i possibili scenari futuri di
acidificazione dei nostri oceani
così come vengono predetti da questi
modelli dei geochimici sono sistemi che
noi abbiamo chiamato le finestre sul
futuro cioè le finestre sul futuro
climatico dei nostri mari e sono così
interessanti che nel 2016
la national geographic society che è
collegata con il magazine con scilla
geografiche conoscerete tutti ci ha
finanziato un progetto un progetto
internazionale
e attualmente noi chiudiamo cinque
sistemi cinque sistemi di riferimento
che si estendono in un range di
profondità fra i due è addirittura il 50
metri e che coinvolgono una serie di
habitat che sono tra i più comuni tra i
più diffusi è tra i più diversificati
che abbiamo nel mediterraneo quindi sono
rappresentativi di una vastissima gamma
di sistemi noi abbiamo sistemi rocciosi
a dominanza con dominanza delle
macroalghe delle macrofite sia
superficiale che più profondi abbiamo
sistemi dominati dalla pianta marina la
posidonia oceanica che un vero e proprio
polmone del mediterraneo forma foreste
sottomarine di un'importanza vitale per
la per la fascia costiera
abbiamo anche sabbie abbiamo un sistema
che è unico al mondo e che è una una
grotta semisommersa la grotta del mago a
ischia ed è l'unico sistema di grotta
acidificato che ha conosciuto al mondo
attualmente in cui è possibile studiare
anche ambienti cha figli cioè ambienti a
luce ridotta ognuno di questi sistemi è
in pratica una finestra sul futuro che
ci permette poi di accedere allo studio
in un'ampia gamma di organismi tra i più
tipici e tra i più importanti che noi
abbiamo nei nostri mari
qual è il sistema e vorrei farvi vedere
alcuni dei risultati più salienti di
cosa del sistema che attualmente più
studiato direi più studiare al mondo
perché è stato il primo sistema primo
sistema di questo tipo
naturalmente acidificato studiato al
mondo è stato il castello aragonese di
ischia
voi siete tutti campani ma almeno la
maggior parte sapete che è un po il
simbolo l'icona dell'isola d'ischia le
acque intorno al all'isolotto
soprattutto nella parte che collega con
la strada all isolotto alla al islah
mario cioè a ischia
sono interessate da queste intense
emissioni di co2 che appunto nelle zone
più intense abbassano il valore del ph
addirittura a dei valori molto severi e
anche sotto 74 che è considerata come
vedremo una soglia molto critica per gli
organismi marini
poi via via che le bolle si rarefanno
noi abbiamo un'ampia zona in cui si
registrano valori intermedi di ph che
sono poi quelli che sono previsti che
sono stati diciamo previsti per la fine
di questo secolo quindi sono le vere
finestre sul futuro più immediato dei
nostri mari e degli oceani fino ad
arrivare alle zone in cui le bolle
cessano e quindi abbiamo zone di
controllo che noi consiglieri
consideriamo zone a ph normale quindi di
controllo quindi abbiamo questo
gradiente da un acidificazione molto
severa le condizioni di controllo che ci
permette lungo questo gradiente di
vedere la variazione delle comunità di
singole specie ma di lavorare anche
sulla loro fisiologia sulla genetica
sulla genomica stiamo lavorando su molti
aspetti
qual è l'aspetto più immediato che mi
che mi fa piacere portarvi
all'attenzione è quello che abbiamo
visto ormai in oltre 10 anni di studi
che passando dalle zone di controllo a
zona via via più certificate sia una
riduzione piuttosto notevole della
biodiversità cioè del numero di specie
che sono in grado
via via che le condizioni diventano più
acide quindi con un fattore di stress è
molto più forte si selezionano e via via
scompaiono perché non riescono più a
sopportare questi livelli molto bassi
del ph o non riescono a sopportare le
fluttuazioni molto elevate di questo
parametro
quindi noi abbiamo una situazione che
abbiamo definito molti perdenti molte
specie perdenti e pochi poche specie
vincitori che riescono invece a
resistere
e chiaro a noi come biologi e da un
punto di vista anche della fisiologia
interessano sia i perdenti sia i
vincitori perché i vincitori ci dicono
quali meccanismi per con quali
meccanismi riescono a resistere
i perdenti ci dicono con quali
meccanismi non riescono a resistere
questo trend di riduzione della
diversità è molto evidente sia negli
organismi animali
costruiamo invertebrati ma anche pesci e
sia negli organismi vegetali anche se
per paradosso gli organismi vegetali
sono tra i pochi che in teoria
dovrebbero essere diciamo favoriti tra
virgolette da dai livelli di
acidificazione perché la co2
entra e uno degli e delle specie
chimiche che entra nel processo della
fotosintesi
in realtà nelle zona cd ficcata noi
abbiamo un surplus di produzione
vegetale male specie comunque si
riducono quindi comunque la diversità
diminuisce e sia quasi il 50 per cento
delle specie che scompaiono quindi sia
un dimezzamento della biodiversità già a
quei livelli di ph che si prevedono per
la fine di questo secolo e cioè quasi un
70 per cento delle specie che scompaiono
quando questi valori di ph si abbassa
ulteriormente sotto questa soglia di 74
che sembra essere un effetto soglia
molto molto severo per molte forme
ovviamente questo scenario diventa più
critico più severo se noi prendiamo in
considerazione nel nostro gradiente e
nelle nostre comunità selezioniamo cosa
solo gli organismi calcificati cioè i
calcari che io vi dicevo saranno quelli
che saranno ancora più penalizzati
dall'acidificazione per la mancanza di
carbonati e per l'ambiente più corrosivo
che dissolve i loro i loro scheletri
effettivamente se vediamo i calcare sia
una riduzione di oltre il 50 per cento
delle specie mobili e di quasi l'ottanta
per cento 80 per cento delle specie
calcare fisse cioè di quelli che una
volta attaccate non si possono più
muovere quindi è chiaro che lì e solo lì
restano e se le condizioni non sono
buone
lì muoiono quindi sì anche in questo
caso una riduzione della diversità
funzionale cioè dei ruoli dei gruppi
trofici o del numero di specie che
contribuisce a quella determinata
categoria
diciamo che in altre parole c'è un
impoverimento generale ecologico sia del
numero di specie sia del numero di
funzioni allora questo scenario è
veramente abbastanza preoccupante ed è
interessante perché queste osservazioni
che noi facciamo a livello locale hanno
sicuramente delle ripercussioni e hanno
delle proiezioni che possono essere
fatte praticamente in tutti ambienti
molto simili che abbiamo in mediterraneo
e per alcuni aspetti anche concettuali
di ecologia di base che possono essere
estrapolate praticamente agli oceani del
globo
e qui volevo terminare con un concetto
che mi preme e cioè che in ecologia in
realtà non c'è niente di locale che
senti che non sia inserito perizia
inseribile in problematiche generali e
molto club e globali e per fare questo
ci vuole una conoscenza molto profonda
del territorio e non solo una conoscenza
del territorio mano conoscenza a lungo
termine del territorio ok che ci
permetta di vedere proprio le differenze
il cambiamento climatico non puoi dire
che cambia una cosa se tu non hai uno
stato iniziale quindi e non c'è niente
di globale a una scala così globale che
al che possiamo non percepire noi nella
nostra quotidianità che invece non abbia
un esempio sul locale io credo che i
nostri sistemi di emissioni di co2 del
golfo di napoli unici al mondo da questo
punto di vista sia un bell'esempio di
questo a livello locale perché ci
permettono di estrapolare scena
e di avere previsioni sul medio lungo
termine come potranno reagire
alcuni ecosistemi importantissimi della
fascia costiera sia a livello del
mediterraneo sia più in generale a
livello di tutti diciamo gli oceani del
nostro pianeta
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]